chief washington correspondent that's
major garrett joins us now
major let's pick up where uh ben just
left where he said for the first time
if he stays on script and sometimes the
president does not do that
that he's going to mention
president-elect joe biden by name he has
shattered so many norms so many things
that we take
uh that we value that we honor what does
it mean that he
has not honored the tradition of of
of the handoff so your successor what is
the common thread in what you just
described gail
the self-generated drama of donald trump
we're all hanging around to see if he
will do something we know he should have
done weeks and months ago and every one
of his
outgoing president presidential
predecessors did without any
worry or concern at all he is built up
and created a false drama about whether
he's going to say the thing
that is so obvious that is so clear-cut
and is so deeply a part of our ingrained
traditions of a transition of power
it is an act of extravagant selfishness
you can't describe it as anything other
than that
yes he's entitled to it he retains the
powers of the presidency
but this is a moment and politics is an
enterprise where you have to do things
you don't want to
sometimes in human life we respect
people who we know
gosh if i was there it'd be really hard
for me to do that but grace matters
matters and history records it as such
so this is
a a day of the president's own creation
the drama built up around it
i think the question that comes to mind
is is this a character flaw as some
republicans have come to
determine or is it something strategic
that the president wants
for attention for attention's sake it is
a character reality
let me go back to a greek philosopher
you might have heard of heraclitus
a man's character is his fate the
smallness of this moment i talked to so
many trump
supporters people really worked inside
the white house really close this
campaign last night
they were unbelievably sad about this
moment how small it is
yeah how it could have been about a
transition of power and a recognition of
accomplishments
all that is so diminished because of the
president's own
actions he has diminished the exit of
his presidency
he could be large and gracious and talk
about the things he has done which are
not insignificant
but all of that is lost because of this
false hyper-generated drama
about nothing major he's leaving the
white house
here in a moment but he is still going
to be president in washington the
subject of an impeachment trial yes
mitch mcconnell on the floor of the
senate yesterday blamed him
again directly for the assault on the
capitol what did you make of those
remarks it was an extraordinary moment
you hear mitch mcconnell so there are a
lot of people in town who consider mitch
mcconnell kind of a cynical inside
player
very mechanistic but there are moments
when he protects the institution of
which he
serves and loves he is an
institutionalist whether you regard him
as a positive or negative one i'll leave
that to the partisans to fight out
but what i heard in those remarks were
mr president you launched an
attack on my home the legislative branch
of our government
the first branch of our government
outlined in the constitution i will not
forget it and is a very good chance i
won't
forgive it and the instrument of my not
forgiving you
is laying before this body in the next
couple of days it's called impeachment
isn't he sending others a message to
that you know what
maybe we should vote well he is
certainly giving them
ample room to have an open mind about
the underlying evidence and he's already
said
yes the president incited mobs the mob
was fed lies
by the president i was so struck by the
fact he did this
on the president's last full day in
office yes he would have said nothing he
could have said nothing
and i think for the senate majority
leader the relationship with the
president has always been strained but
the
majority leaders always said look i've
given you lots of room
lots of latitude to do your presidency
in your particularly
combative way what does it say i've
lived with that but i can't live with
this i can't abide this and i
won't let it go mitch mcconnell's very
carefully chosen words on his last day
as majority leader
do raise the question and we'll put this
to reince priebus later the president's
former chief of staff
of whether there is a permanent fracture
underway
in the republican party we heard someone
yesterday in a piece from manny
bojorquez refer to themselves as a
trumplikin
sure is that the future it might be in
the remarks the president's about to
give he will talk about the movement and
that it's in its earliest days
and it's going to continue and grow
around what
is it going to grow around the toxic
lies
of the last days of his presidency which
can only be described as a
assault not only on democracy the
capital but on facts and truth
and this reluctance to embrace the idea
that there's a transition of power and
someone new has been elected president
is that what your new party is about is
that your definition of patriotism if
you're going to call the patriot party
that's going to be a tough sell that is
not an enduring american political
message
if it gets closer to aggressiveness on
immigration
trade and things like that maybe it can
last but republicans are going to have
to make a decision about what they stand
for conspiracy theories
lies and anti-constitutionalist behavior
or something that's much more common in
the republican party oh front or about
160 years
i thought it was interesting too when
mitch mcconnell said not only lies by
the president but lies
by people powerful people people in
power
i thought he was sending messages there
as well yes you can read between the
lines ted cruz josh
so this moment as we await the
president's departure from the white
house and we are on the day when joe
biden and kamala harris will be
inaugurated it really underscores the
degree to which this is a break in what
is normal in washington on a typical
inauguration day we wouldn't have
multiple cameras and far-flung
correspondents we would have a single
shot
right of the incoming and outgoing
president exchanging gifts and
pleasantries on the white house steps
right and it doesn't mean that we have
to assume that everything is pleasant
and everyone loves each other that's not
the point
the point is in america we have
a lot of campaigning and we say lots of
tough things about one another but when
the voters
have made their verdict clear we don't
come apart we come together even if it's
ever so briefly and even if it's just
for ceremony
we do it to show the world and to show
ourselves
that these underlying traditions not
only matter in a historic sense
but they matter in a future sense
repeating them
inculcates us in very good behavior
that's
central not to our political futures not
to our political parties
but to the country itself valerie
jarrett made that point yesterday when
she joined us at cbs this morning she
said it was a difficult time for the
obamas right
to greet the trumps at the white house
that day because michelle obama's
written about this in her book
she believes that president trump's
rhetoric has actually put her family in
danger
but yet she said they chose grace at
that particular time right and if you go
back and look at president trump's
inaugural address
the very beginning of it he turns and
says i want to say how magnificent
president obama and first lady michelle
have been to us the transition has been
excellent
you have been magnificent big round of
applause but then in that speech we
heard the phrase
american carnage but still but the point
of that what i just said is that they
acknowledged one another as difficult as
it was
and this seamless garment of american
democracy was visible
it is rent this morning it will be torn
and the president is tearing it and
he's not going to be there and what that
sets up i mean to the point you're
making now major this
this is joe biden's day the focus should
be on joe biden
and we're spending time talking about
the fact that donald trump won't go to
the inauguration well you know what we
can try
maybe we should not do that we shouldn't
do that we can turn the hourglass over
right now
from where i begin this artificial drama
which keeps the president at the center
of it that's the common thread